Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, the final episode of the whole series, Episode Nineteen: climate.
Global warming, a global problem.
Consumption of large amounts of energy, in the form of burning coal, oil and gas, together called fossil fuels, within, among other things, production and transport, has been decisive for creating the last 150 years' great economic growth.
But it has also led to a large emission of CO2 and other so-called greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
People speak of greenhouse gases and the "greenhouse effect" because these gases, like a greenhouse, on the one hand let the sun's rays in, but on the other hand limit the heat from escaping again.
The more greenhouse gases there are in the atmosphere, the less heat is let out of the atmosphere again.
It affects the climate, so that global warming takes place, which threatens worldwide to create more areas covered by desert, more floods and more extreme heat.
The consequence will be that people will find it harder to live in large parts of the world.
It is more than 100 years since this greenhouse effect was discovered.
At that time people thought it would take thousands of years before it became a problem.
But it went much faster.
Now we know that the emission of CO2 and other greenhouse gases has already affected our climate.
In comparison with the period 1850 to 1900, the global climate has become more than one degree warmer.
Historically that is a big change in a little over 100 years.
Especially in recent decades it has gone fast, and the development seems to continue even faster.
The UN predicts that the climate will become 2.3 to 2.5 degrees warmer at the end of this century than it was in the period 1850 to 1900.
For Denmark to contribute to counteracting this development, a number of steps have been taken in recent decades to reduce Danes' emission of greenhouse gases.
That has meant that Denmark's emissions since 1990 have fallen by about 47 percent.
But globally the emission of greenhouse gases has risen a lot in the same period, because the Earth's population is growing fast, and more people get money to buy more.
That requires more production, and thereby more greenhouse gases are let out into the atmosphere.
Denmark emits about one thousandth, one in a thousand, of the world's climate gases.
The problem can therefore only be solved if other countries also reduce their emissions.
Therefore international cooperation is crucial.
The world's countries have, not least in the UN, had focus on solving the problem.
A number of international agreements have been entered into, including the so-called Paris Agreement in 2015, which obliges almost all the world's countries to contribute to reducing the global emission of greenhouse gases over the coming decades.
In addition there are agreements within the EU with higher ambitions than the Paris Agreement.
The Danish climate effort.
In recent years climate has had a lot of room on the political agenda in Denmark.
Opinion polls show that the subject has been important to many voters, and several large demonstrations have been held to put pressure on the politicians to do more to protect the climate.
In 2014 the Climate Council, Klimarådet, was established.
It is to advise the government on climate questions, assess the government's climate policy and put forward its own recommendations.
In its advice the Climate Council must among other things focus on greenhouse gas emissions being reduced in a way that does not cost citizens, companies and society too much money and too many jobs.
In 2019, most political parties agreed on a new climate act, klimaloven.
The climate act obliges the government up to 2030 to reduce Denmark's emission of greenhouse gases by 70 percent compared with 1990.
In addition the climate act also obliges to secure full climate neutrality for Denmark in 2050.
That is, Denmark must not emit more greenhouse gases than the country absorbs.
Since the climate act was adopted, the Folketing and the government have agreed a number of measures that are to serve to reach the goals.
The road to reaching these goals is to go via the so-called "green" transition.
The green transition is about moving away from using "black" energy sources such as oil and gas, which emit a lot of greenhouse gases, and moving over to using renewable and green energy sources such as for example sun, wind and hydropower.
These energy sources are called renewable because they do not run out, and they are green because they emit no or far fewer greenhouse gases than the black energy sources.
And the development is going in the right direction, even though there is a long way still to go.
In 2024 about 50 percent of Denmark's energy consumption was covered by renewable energy, against six percent in 1990.
Of the renewable energy sources, wind energy is not least important in Denmark, which has had wind turbines on land since the 1970s and in 1991 set up the world's first offshore wind farm, Vindeby, off Lolland.
In 2025 wind turbines produced 52 percent of Denmark's electricity consumption.
Denmark has since 2020 taken a significant step to expand wind energy further.
As the first country in the world, Denmark has decided to build a so-called energy island, which is to be built in the mid-2030s.
The energy island is to lie by Bornholm and send electricity to both Zealand and Germany.
It is to give electricity to many millions of people in different European countries.
In May 2025 it was decided in Denmark to put out to tender at least 2.8 gigawatts of offshore wind, distributed over three different offshore wind farms, two in the North Sea and one in inner Danish waters at Hesselø in Kattegat.
The offshore wind farms will together be able to deliver green electricity to just under three million households.
Work is also going on, partly on more efficient heating of houses, apartments and so on, and partly that it is green energy that is used for this heating.
Greater requirements are continuously made for insulation of buildings and so on to save on energy consumption, and there is public support for homeowners to get their oil or gas boilers replaced by heat pumps or by district heating.
Heat pumps use heat from, for example, ground and air and raise the temperature with electricity, while district heating is based on central heating plants that use for example biomass or larger heat pumps.
In addition, car taxes have been arranged according to how much the cars emit of greenhouse gases.
It is a goal that there should be many more cars that run on electricity, electric cars, rather than cars that run on petrol or diesel.
Earlier Europe bought a lot of oil and gas from Russia.
The import has however been reduced considerably since Russia's attack on Ukraine in 2022, at the same time as interest in green energy has grown further, because it can make Europe more independent of Russian energy.
Denmark has, among other things together with several North Sea countries, the Netherlands, Belgium, Germany, the United Kingdom, Norway and others, agreed that towards 2050 very many new wind turbines are to be built in the North Sea area.
The Green Tripartite, Grøn Trepart.
Part of the emission of greenhouse gases also comes from agriculture, which makes up 60 percent of Denmark's area.
That makes Denmark one of the countries in the world where the largest share of the land is cultivated agricultural land.
Conversion of agriculture therefore also has crucial importance for Denmark's climate effort.
Therefore the government, the municipalities and a number of business organisations, trade unions and environmental organisations have entered into a cooperation called "Den Grønne Trepart", the Green Tripartite.
The parties behind the Green Tripartite agreed in 2024 a big and comprehensive plan to create more nature in Denmark and cleaner water in lakes, streams and the sea.
And to convert agriculture so that it pollutes less.
It has been agreed that about 15 percent of Denmark's agricultural land, corresponding to an area larger than Funen and Bornholm together, is to be converted to nature, by planting new forest and establishing new meadows and other natural areas.
In that connection it is of great importance that so-called low-lying land, lavbundsjord, is converted to nature.
Low-lying land is agricultural land that lies low in damp, marshy areas, filled with dead plant remains, which contain a lot of carbon, which is released when the soil is cultivated.
Low-lying land thus makes up only seven percent of Denmark's agricultural land but is the cause of about half of the CO2 emission from agriculture.
Denmark's coastal areas and fjords have in several places been hit by oxygen depletion, that is falling amounts of oxygen, which make it harder for fish and other nature to live in the water.
This oxygen depletion is not least due to agriculture's fertilising of the fields.
The agreement therefore aims especially to convert the agricultural areas that emit nitrogen to vulnerable water areas.
In addition the agreement means that Denmark as the first country in the world has chosen to introduce a direct tax on agriculture's emission of CO2, the so-called "CO2 tax", so farmers must pay for emission of CO2 especially from their cows, pigs, sheep, hens and other animals.
The tax has created political discussion and has among other things been criticised for moving food production and jobs out of the rural districts and out of Denmark.
Others have criticised the tax for being too low to be able to reduce the emission of CO2 sufficiently.
Here is your recap for Episode Nineteen, and for Chapter Six.
Burning fossil fuels, coal, oil and gas, emits CO2 and other greenhouse gases that cause the greenhouse effect.
The global climate has become more than one degree warmer than in 1850 to 1900; the UN predicts 2.3 to 2.5 degrees by the end of the century.
Denmark's emissions have fallen about 47 percent since 1990, but Denmark emits only about one thousandth of the world's climate gases.
The Paris Agreement dates from 2015.
The Climate Council was established in 2014.
The climate act of 2019 obliges a 70 percent reduction by 2030 compared with 1990, and climate neutrality in 2050.
In 2024 about 50 percent of energy consumption was renewable, against six percent in 1990.
The world's first offshore wind farm, Vindeby, off Lolland, was set up in 1991.
In 2025 wind turbines produced 52 percent of electricity consumption, making wind energy, vindenergi, Denmark's biggest renewable source of electricity, far ahead of solar energy and wave energy.
Agriculture covers 60 percent of Denmark, almost two thirds, opdyrket landbrugsjord.
The Paris-aftalen is about climate, klima: reducing udslippet af drivhusgasser.
The energy island by Bornholm is planned for the mid-2030s.
In May 2025 at least 2.8 gigawatts of offshore wind was put out to tender.
Heat pumps and district heating replace oil and gas boilers.
In 2024 the Green Tripartite agreed that about 15 percent of agricultural land is to be converted to nature, with low-lying land the priority; low-lying land is seven percent of farmland but half of agriculture's CO2 emission.
Denmark was the first country to introduce a CO2 tax on agriculture.
That brings us to the end of the whole series.
Congratulations on completing all six chapters of the Danish citizenship exam companion.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What are Denmark and a number of other countries especially committed to under the Paris Agreement from 2015?
Option A: To reduce the emission of greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
Option B: To spend more money on defence.
Option C: To cooperate on preventing cross-border crime.
[DA] Hvad er Danmark og en række andre lande især forpligtet til ifølge Paris-aftalen fra 2015?  A: At reducere udslippet af drivhusgasser i atmosfæren  |  B: At bruge flere penge på forsvaret  |  C: At samarbejde om forebyggelse af grænseoverskridende kriminalitet
The answer is A: To reduce the emission of greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
It appeared in the June 2022 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: At reducere udslippet af drivhusgasser i atmosfæren
Question 2.
What is the Paris Agreement, which the UN adopted in 2015, especially about?
Option A: Climate.
Option B: Defence.
Option C: Crime.
[DA] Hvad handler Paris-aftalen, som FN vedtog i 2015, især om?  A: Klima  |  B: Forsvar  |  C: Kriminalitet
The answer is A: Climate.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Klima
Question 3.
Which type of renewable energy produces the largest share of Denmark's electricity consumption?
Option A: Solar energy.
Option B: Wind energy.
Option C: Wave energy.
[DA] Hvilken type vedvarende energi producerer den største andel af Danmarks el-forbrug?  A: Solenergi  |  B: Vindenergi  |  C: Bølgeenergi
The answer is B: Wind energy.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Vindenergi
Question 4.
What was agreed in the Green Tripartite, Den Grønne Trepart, in June 2024?
Option A: That part of Denmark's agricultural land is to be converted to nature.
Option B: To reduce the quotas for how much may be fished in Danish waters.
Option C: To raise public support for electric cars.
[DA] Hvad blev aftalt i 'Den Grønne Trepart' mellem regeringen, kommunerne og en række erhvervsorganisationer, fagforeninger og miljøorganisationer i juni 2024?  A: At en del af Danmarks landbrugsjord skal omdannes til natur  |  B: At reducere kvoterne for, hvor meget der må fiskes i dansk farvand  |  C: At forhøje den offentlige støtte til el-biler
The answer is A: That part of Denmark's agricultural land is to be converted to nature.
It appeared in the November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: At en del af Danmarks landbrugsjord skal omdannes til natur
That's the end of this part.
Well done.